[Music]
as flattered as I am that you would use
me as a couples therapist
it is my non-professional opinion that
you should seek in actual professional
but you're the only one crazy enough to
understand us
yeah and to be fair we do usually get
along better when we take you I can't
you're well well I think kidnap so many
times at this point there's probably a
plumber constantly being told that I'm
in another castle what can I say we're
bound tighter when you're bound tighter
and I can practice my arts and crafts on
your manacles yes they're lovely Thanks
so let's get to the heart of the
argument rather not talk about it good
I'd rather not hear about it key please
it's just that we thought that we agreed
on every single thing and we found out
that there's one major hiccup the Evil
Dead movies yeah if I had a nickel for
every couple of those broke up he
prefers the remake even though the
original is the cult classic it's cooler
and more realistic demons possessing
people how is that more realistic I can
tell you some things the funny thing is
is kind of amazing we're having this
conversation at all the original Evil
Dead a horror film about a group of
people being possessed by spirits is
still considered a cult classic
it puts Sam Raimi and Bruce Campbell on
the map led to hugely entertaining
sequels and still stands as one of the
most uniquely corny yet somehow badass
horror films ever made so when it was
announced a remake was coming out people
reacted how everybody reacts when they
hear a remake is coming out it was
betraying what was perfect don't fix
what's not broken something about
fucking your mother with a chainsaw it's
the internet you know somebody said that
yet when the movie came out many people
were surprisingly open to it they said
it was different enough to be its own
thing yet had just enough callbacks and
practical effects to make it a loving
send up the blood hit the fan and a lot
of people seemed to have a gory good
time well most people come on that never
works I know you can hear me
but not me now good therapist will tell
you that disagreement is the core of
compromise and being open to a new point
of view helped you grow as a couple
thankfully I'm not a good therapist so I
say fight until somebody wins yeah so
strap yourself in whether you have a
choice or not I don't have a choice do I
yeah kind of figured this is old versus
new the evil dead
the one thing to keep in mind is we're
only doing the first Evil Dead movie not
any of the sequels
so put away your phone a chainsaw hand
for badass credit points card oh but
this is literally the only time that I
can ever use this
don't worry punches I'll find other
times let's start with story
in many respects the stories are very
similar to groups of people go to a
cabin in the middle of the woods where
they discovered the book of the dead
they idiotic ly read it out loud
summoning the evil spirits and one by
one the people are possessed killed off
or maimed in some sort of beautifully
grotesque way exactly they're so similar
what's even the point
well the remake does have a few
additions in the original they're just
going for a getaway but in the new one
they're going as a means to get their
friend off drugs not only does this
already start off on an uncomfortable
level but it makes the belief of the
supernatural all the more nerve-wracking
because they think it's all just part of
her withdrawal on top of that she and
her brother have a mother who went crazy
so both of them have a fear of losing
control and not mentally knowing what's
going on the story suddenly has more
purpose as these siblings are not only
trying to stop these things both
mentally and physically but they're also
trying to figure out what's real and
what's not it also starts off as any
psychologically challenging film should
my mind as hell the first film they just
arrived at the cabin but in this one
this chick is knocked out her dad's
gonna burn her alive for some reason
that Eraserhead baby is there a noise
she's fired up does she reveal her
resting bitchface then pop goes the evil
that's how you start a gory movie blood
was the point of all that blood anything
you guys don't my affair phone for help
do you know go ahead fine
I know it's technically the people that
were there before but we barely know
anything about them like who was that
Eraserhead baby guy yeah the original
starts off simple and unassuming you
have no idea what you're in for
The Book of the Dead is discovered and
you have no idea what it can do
building up the suspense you also hear
more about who these people are
seemingly kind folks who stumble across
something awful which makes it even more
uncomfortable building up what's coming
the remake gives away too much too soon
you think that was pointless how about
getting what Oh snookums later no I mean
literally this yeah the woman getting
what what was the point in that then it
was kind of a good point in the remake
there is a similar scene but it doesn't
show as much detail and is clearly done
to show how the character is getting
possessed the original was definitely
done to play up the shock value and
exploitation vibe even though as far as
I know it doesn't really tie into
anything oh come on just me
the guy who came up with this insisted
on vacuform shirts naked women in Chains
and ended up marrying Xena Warrior
Princess everyone thinks he has an issue
or two
well the creators of the first one
definitely said they want to make the
most shocking horror film at the time so
it gets a lot of the random gore violins
and scenes that don't really seem to
have much explanation all fall under the
rationale of just trying to get an
uncomfortable reaction like any horror
film I guess but even then they keep it
to just the people in the cabin who
attack who the hell is this girl at the
end of the remake oh that's the girl in
the book based on the girl on the poster
based on the maybe girl who got shot in
the intro jinx right right but who cares
look what she does to this ending feels
tagged on making the story feel longer
and it's a happy ending what the hell oh
I forgot you don't believe in Happy
Endings Oh puppy King you can't pop you
can't you're way out of this one
actually you're both kind of right well
the ending does drag a bit it does still
give us some good Gore and a literal
blood storm yeah it makes no sense but I
think that's part of the course for
these movies in fact the majority of the
remake has good fast pacing usually
jumping from one crazy Gore fest to
another with little time to take a
breath
the original is much slower not only
getting to the bloodbath but also in the
breaks it takes I know this is for mood
and character but let's be honest that's
not what people are exactly here for
they're here to see crazy shit happen
and that only does the remake cut to the
crazy shit faster but they give an
additional edge with two of the
characters not knowing what to believe
giving them little time to regain their
senses and look over the situation while
the ending does feel drawn-out the rest
of the film moves arguably smoother than
the original which moves much slower but
ends exactly where it should end no I
mean leaving it open for two sequels and
a TV series of course
so when adding everything up the story
in the remake is better because it adds
more of what's needed and takes out more
of what's not yeah
how much of my ceiling is still standing
I don't know they said it has a long
history of people crashing through and
shooting at it yeah you should really
get that look down little preoccupied at
the moment
oh it's like you to gloat it's like you
to goat what you heard me
yeah I did but I didn't get it do you
didn't get it to spite me okay it's not
my intention to anger the man who
dresses in guns so why don't we use the
puppets that my therapy book slash how
to survive a hostage situation recommend
yeah I guess we could do that sure you
just can't beat the main actor in the
original films its Bruce Campbell for
God's sakes yeah but he was barely an
actor
are you using that voice no just silly
that's how we should talk well you're
not supposed to use a funny voice you're
just posted like top chunk well then why
are we using him at all
why are we using are you doing the voice
again how's that supposed to help it's
supposed to help you say things that you
would never say oh you mean like they
originally vote that is bad I don't like
playing dolls with you my mini boner you
just drive my mini boner I'll kill ya oh
my god I killed her you killed her I
kill puppet you you killed puppet me do
we bury her in a shoebox or how this
works she wanted to be cremated puppet
you is very specific well she prepared
for everything except for you killing
her ass alright let me find a fireplace
Christ this is best main character
now this is really difficult because
while one is a really good actress with
a Great backstory and wide range yeah
there is Bruce fucking Campbell come on
it's Bruce Campbell
nobody can just like anything he does
it's like a commandment but there is one
major problem this is a really the ash
we've all come to know and love
he's not a badass he's not a lying quote
er he's not a larger-than-life screw-up
he's just a guy not even a very
interesting guy when danger comes along
he usually just stands around and does
nothing his name isn't even Ashe it's
Ashley what a bizarre naming choice is
that one the next one that give one of
the women two boys names it's like
calling John Wayne Daisy Orion writes
Howard or Stevie Wonder Steam land but
what's in a name as long as the
character is cool and honestly this is
not a cool character he's the dweeb he's
the loser he's the guy you kind of
forget about so that it surprises you
when he's the one that survives at the
end mia is kind of a similar fake-out
she's the first one to get possessed so
you naturally think she's going to die
but through some very strange demonic
loopholes she ends up coming back and
the brother gets axed
however the reign she has to go through
is amazing she has to be pissed off but
compose which drawing getting possessed
going back and forth between reality and
crazy town and then she has to be the
fighting hero at the end in a sense she
kind of plays every role you can play in
a horror film it's like a one-woman Gore
show plus she's the greatest combination
of golem and Grima Wormtongue ever ash
in the first film is just kind of the
victim he does eventually fight back but
not in a way that makes us want to cheer
for him
the remake surprisingly has more ash
qualities than the original ash despite
her not even playing the same character
don't get me wrong
ash has got some funny lines and he's
entertaining but in comparing the two
there's just a lot more in both writing
and performing with the remake but this
ash gives birth to the Cowardly badass
that we all know and love but that's not
what's represented here if there were no
other movies
and we just had to judge these two on
their own Mia would be the more
interesting character kitten mush what
are you doing I don't know I'm agreeing
with him and yet my hand wants to kill
him based on less outcomes gonna be I
can't believe I'm saying this but Mia is
the much better character compared to
Ashley nah - Ashley I agree with that
but my hand wants to kill a person
gaming bad about first Campbell I don't
have control you know what needs to be
done I'm gonna lop off my Bruce Timm 11
hands what that's crazy
maybe but who's laughing now
excessive yeah like I should really just
grow up yeah this Miceli boy goes to the
new
but you can't have a horror film without
a lineup of bodies or a rescue what the
hell
Benny thank guys you got my message get
me out of here man we can do this the
easy way or the fun way oh no you don't
agent J there's no way you're gonna get
in the way of our little feud with the
Evil Dead movies oh you're doing the
Evil Dead movies can I join sure yes
thanks I could never make up my mind of
which one I like more you know I could
talk about those movies to death so
[Laughter]
which part are you eh
oh I was talking about the supportive
backup that ends up being a lifeless
lump on the log or couch mmm
I do love fiction that's fucking
supporting cast
if I remember correctly neither of these
movies had particularly strong backup
characters
yeah the support in both versions is
pretty by the numbers they both clearly
exist just to be victims to either be
killed off or possessed when they get
possessed they're a lot of fun each one
would creative ways to look grotesque
gooey and horrifying but that still
doesn't mean they have much personality
before they're taken over the closest
was probably the brother in the second
version because he at least had a
concern for his sister's mental health
which ties into the fear of his mental
health as well but we know he's not
gonna go crazy
yeah just bagging up his sister's head
and burying her alive what your brother
never did that to you there's also a
clever trick where just before the
blonde dies the spirit leaves her body
meaning she can go back to normal this
is great for later when the brother has
no idea if Mia being buried is the real
meow or not but aside from that the
supporting cast doesn't offer that much
and aren't really very memorable the
original Evil Dead has a huge advantage
though it has a sense of humor because
it does have a corny way of doing things
that's both frightening and kind of
funny the performances can be a little
more hammy and not seem out of place in
a weird way there's sometimes awkward
way of saying things helps them stand
out more face and asshole who read book
out loud for no reason oh my god they do
kind of suck their performances are fine
enough so they're not distracting but
they're not strong enough to leave an
impression the originals performances
are just off enough that you remember
them a little more say what you will
about Sam Raimi but there's always
something to remember accept Costner
baseball movie number four what was that
one called I don't remember so in a
strange way the originals ability to be
less convincing but more stylized
actually works better than the remake
which is more convincing but less
interesting the newer ones just didn't
leave their mark dude are you kidding
well scars are gonna be there forever I
mean
memory Oh point goes to the old oh yeah
oh yeah you can take your little mini
boner and shove it up a butt dude too
soon oh I'm sorry snuggles still king
over that I won't ask
but let's stop wasting time and get to
some action in violence right Benny yep
like right now uh-huh
while you're sitting there totally down
getting to the reason you came here you
know it
taking out the two people sitting next
to you I'm finding it harder to put a
spin on that but yes is this best core
oh what a bloody mess of a bloody mess
the Goron these movies are awesome but
it's the best in the new one it looks
more real more painful more disgusting
you're missing the point though it's not
about how real it looks it's about how
creative and inspired it is especially
on such a low-budget evil dad has a big
following so of course the remake is
gonna have more money to make it more
real but give them credit at a time
where computers do everything the
majority of the gore is done on set so
all of the effects of the original were
done on set both of these movies have
very creative yet very different ways of
doing their gore the first film focused
more on monster makeup making them look
more like demonic creatures the remake
focus is more on the avenues of
mutilation the monster stuff is mainly
just contacts look at all the crazy ass
ways they're chopped up it's like a
sculpture of clay please it's kind of
hard to see though isn't it there's
often flickering lights are too many
Dark Shadows Oh what there were no live
shadows in the first one they definitely
were but they were shot in a way where
you can make them out better yeah you
can make out how fake it is I can't even
you can't you have I'm Binney it's true
the film's low-budget shows more in the
original but not only is that part of
the fun it also allows us to question
the ingenuity you know if anything went
wrong in the remake they could and
probably did just digitally alter it
with the original
what-you-see-is-what-you-get so there's
not only a greater feeling of
authenticity but also a greater
appreciation for it this effect of the
animates scars growing took an hour to
animate live on set and the weight of
that time is felt in those few seconds
being fair the remake must have taken a
lot of time - it's true when the efforts
show the effects look a lot more juicy
and fleshy even the Book of the Dead
actually looks like it was bound in
human flesh and not burnt bean dip
they're still impressive and go to the
extremes for their kills
but again the originals low-budget is
not only impressive for what they did on
so little but it also
somehow feels more painful when somebody
gets injured in the remake it's
inventive but you don't really feel the
pain in the original even when it looks
fake you feel how much it would have
hurt part of that could be because a lot
of the actors were getting hurt they
didn't have enough for stunt people so
half the time when someone really got
hurt they just left it in there was less
protection and therefore more risk and
that tension comes through the acting
and makeup if they all look like they
only have one shot to fight something
off it's because mostly they did only
have only one shot I'm sure the original
actors had to go through a
pain-in-the-ass shoot - but compared a
tracking shot from the remake to a
tracking shot in the original branches
are hitting the camera it's shaky it's
getting gunk on it this is the kind of
unprepared feeling that follows you
throughout the whole film which
surprisingly works to its advantage the
other can look dirty too but it's also a
lot more smooth and less shaky and you
feel a little bit more of the
manipulation not a ton just in
comparison to the original and on top of
that more variety in the different types
of blood scars Monsters and techniques
and you have a competition that's close
but still favoring the original point
goes to the old
that's two that went to not my side the
next one better go to the remake or
everyone's gonna ask what's that bowl of
SpaghettiOs that used to be the
nostalgia critic spice or it can go to
the original so I won't have to
surgically remove my foot from the
exploded remains of what used to be your
testicles these are really good chips
well see how there's no way out of this
without a huge amount of pain a lot a
lot amount of pain let's just go to the
final category atmosphere
in a horror film atmosphere is
everything whether getting people to
scream laugh or both there has to be a
unique environment and feel that puts
you in a unique mood both films have a
lot of silence and both films have a lot
of screaming they both know how to
utilize it and when to surprise people
with something unexpected I guess in
some respects the remake has the
disadvantage because everyone has an
idea of what's coming but it was
different enough and so in its own world
that when it did follow something from
the original we almost forgot that oh
yeah this is a remake we weren't
shouting where's this scene or where's
that line we instead enjoyed whatever
new direction it was trying to take us
but the biggest problem is that the
remake is well very well done just
another horror film we've seen these
kind of character scenarios and even
effects done in dozens of other movies
while the setup to the original has
certainly been done to death
everything else is uniquely its own the
camerawork the odd pacing the weird
acting the strange effects all of these
fall under a genre that you could argue
Evil Dead almost created people were
laughing and screaming while watching it
and all the problems that usually work
against a movie we're working towards
making it one of the most unique scary
films ever made the new Evil Dead did
its job very well beyond expectations
even but it's not gonna break any
landmarks it had to be a little safer
and more dramatic because it had to show
they were taking this remake seriously
there was no way out of that it could
make a reference or two with the
chainsaw and such but it could never
wink too hard at the audience because it
would feel too gimmicky because of this
it was hard for the film to have any
sense of humor the original Evil Dead of
course has a great sense of humor
sometimes intentional sometimes not but
it was always present that's a big part
of what made it stand out it's not the
remakes fault for any of these problems
honestly I don't know how you could
really work around it it's amazing that
they got the product that they did
something different but still familiar
enough to be a loving homage to a
classic however that's
what it is and omage to a classic a
classic that can't always be defined
repeated or even fully understood
it's a rare kind of insanity that stands
on its own where even the bad stuff is
good it holds up in how much it doesn't
hold up it's timeless yet totally dated
it's shocking but not in a shocking way
even to this day it doesn't always add
up it's just kind of its own entity and
the remake is trying to recapture what
honestly can't be fully explained
there's an evil dead remake which is
surprisingly good but there is only one
original Evil Dead and it will stay that
way for years and years point goes to
the old winning the match
didn't have to be this way
sure I would have shot some party up but
and be a part that you survive anymore
think about not changing my place that
much but nevertheless you work it my one
regret is not talking like a pirate I
talk like a pirate day give another
chance your own duty trying to kill a
guy well I've never distracted you
before well we've never been in a fight
before I hate fighting with you
bubblegum why don't you razor blade but
how we got some our differences you know
I do have a brother that specializes in
just this sort of thing I see so me
refusing to back down comes from my fear
of artichokes mm-hmm and my need for
attention comes through my past of
wrestling polar bears hmm by God it all
makes sense
you finally cured us thank you throne
you've given us a new chapter in our
lives that we'll never forget
come surf shooter let's go do stuff
together
[Music]
I miss food
[Applause]
[Music]
you
mm-hmm
hey Doug Walker here doing the charity
shout out this week we're doing the
Pancreatic Cancer Action Network this is
a nationwide network of people dedicated
to working together to advance research
support and create hope for those
affected by pancreatic cancer of the
major cancers pancreatic cancer has the
lowest survival rate in 2010 the
organization declared a bold and
aggressive vision after seeing too
little progress and pancreatic cancer
survival in over half a century
they put a stake in the ground to double
pancreatic cancer survival by 2020 to do
this they're addressing five major needs
clinical trials that match patients
needs higher clinical trial enrollment
rate doctors delivering best practices
and more public awareness and visibility
if you look at their site or their
YouTube page you can see not only the
progress they're making but how you too
can help in bringing this awful illness
to an end take a look here all the
amazing stories and see how you too can
be a part of history
[Music]
you